we're on problem 138
138 in a certain business production
index p is directly proportional to
efficiency index e
so p
so we could say that p is equal to some
proportionality constant times e because
they say p is directly proportional to e
fair enough which is in turn directly
proportional to investment index i
so e
is proportional to i so we could say
it's equal to some proportionality
constant times i
and actually we could go even a step
further and say well e if p is
proportional to e and e is proportional
to i we could also say that p is
proportional to i directly proportional
i so it might be some other constant
some other constant times i and you
could show that you could prove that
mathematically right you take this and
substitute it for e and you get p
is equal to k times e e is equal to some
constant times i
and so p is equal to k n times i
but k and n were both arbitrary
constants so we could just call that m
so this is what this is the information
that the problem gives us p is
proportional to k e is proportional to i
i'm sorry p is proportional to e e is
proportional to i so p is also
proportional to i so what are they
asking us
what is p
p
if
i is equal to 70.
so if we knew this proportional constant
we'd be all set we could actually solve
this problem maybe they're going to go
through e or something i don't know
so statement number one statement number
one
e is equal to 0.5
when
i is equal to 60.
well we can definitely use this
information to figure out what n is
and but that by itself isn't going to
help us because we can figure out what n
is and then once we know what n is we
can figure out what e is when i is 70
because we'll put 70 here times whatever
we figure out n is we'll get e
but without knowing what k is
that still won't help us
so statement 1 by itself if i'm right
isn't
right that won't that won't help us and
i'll show it to you let me oh this would
be a waste of time if you understood
that logic
because you can say 0.5
is equal to n times 60. this is so we
can solve for n so n
is equal to
0.5
over 60
that's the same thing as 1 over
and then you could say so then
that equation boils down to e is equal
to
i over 120 right 1 over 120 times i
so when i is equal to 70 e would be
equal to 70 over 120 which is equal to 7
over 12. but that still doesn't help us
e is equal to 7 over 12 but we don't
know what k is
right when i is equal to 70 e is 7 over
12 but we still don't know what k is
based on just the information in
statement 1.
so as far as i can tell right now 1 by
itself not so useful
statement 2
p is 2
p is equal to 2
when
i is equal to 50.
well this is useful because we already
said p is proportional to i p is equal
to some constant m times i
so we could use this information to
solve for m so p is equal to two
when i is equal to fifty
divide both sides by fifty you get m is
equal to one over twenty five and so the
question was what is p when i is equal
to seventy so we could just say p is
equal to
m
times i well i now is 70.
and whatever 70 divided by 25 is that's
p so statement 2 alone was sufficient to
solve this problem and statement 1
didn't help us much
next problem
if x does not equal
minus y that's interesting
is x minus y
over
x plus y
greater than one
so why did they say x does not equal
minus one
oh sorry x does not equal minus y
well if x were equal to minus y if this
were minus y then you'd have minus y
plus y the denominator would be zero and
you'd be undefined so maybe that's why
they put that out there
so let me try to let's see i think we
could simplify this statement so we
could multiply both sides by x plus y
you get
x minus y
is greater than x plus y
and so this holds true if what let's say
we subtract x from both sides
subtracting x from both sides you get
just get rid of the x's you get minus y
is greater than
y
see we could add y to both sides of this
equation
so the left side if you add y here you
get 0
is greater than if you had a y on this
side you get 2y
and you could divide both sides of this
equation by 2
and you get 0 is greater than y or y is
less than 0 either way so this fairly
hairy looking statement boyle this
statement is true if and only if this
statement is true
so this is really all we need to test
for is y less than zero if we know that
y is less than zero we know that this is
true or if we know this is false and we
know this is false
so statement one statement one tells us
x is greater than zero
well this is useless this actually has
no bearing on whether y is less than
zero x can be anything it doesn't change
this so this by itself is useless
statement two is well there there you go
y is less than zero so statement two
tells us this is true and this is true
if and only if this is true
so therefore statement two alone is
sufficient to answer this question
very seldom do you get do you boil down
the statement to actually one of the
statements that they provide you but
that knows that was interesting
next problem
140.
in the rectangular coordinate system are
the points rs and uv equidistant from
the origin
okay so they're essentially saying is
the distance of the point rs
equal
distance from the origin equal to the
distance from i'll call it d sub o
equals the distance to the origin of
point u
v
and here just to get the intuition of
distance
i always find it silly that they teach
something called a distance formula in
high schools because it's really just
the pythagorean theorem
and by
calling it something different and
making you memorize a different formula
it'll just clutter your head so this is
the x-axis and this is the y-axis the
point rs will be here
this is r
this is s
it's the point r
s
what's its distance from the origin
what's distance from the origin is the
length of this line right there
what's the length of that well we can
use pythagorean theorem the height right
there is s
the base here is r
and if we call this distance we use
pythagorean theorem
r squared plus s squared is equal to the
distance squared right or we could say
that the distance
the distance is equal to the square root
of r squared plus s squared
the distance to the origin
so this statement up here boils down to
that the square root
of r squared plus s squared
needs to be equal to
the square root
of u squared plus v squared
well just to simplify things let's just
square both sides of this equation and
then we're left with the question they
ask is is r squared plus s squared equal
to
u squared plus v squared is this true
that's what they ask us and that kind of
simplifies things makes them more
concrete
so let's see what the statements give us
statement one
r plus s is equal to one
just off the cuff i don't see where
that's going to be actually useful i you
know
it's not like you can just square this r
plus s squared is
r squared plus
two r s plus s squared so you can't just
you know a lot of people make the
mistake that thinking oh r plus f
squared is r squared plus square no
there's that's not true you have to
distribute all the terms and you end up
with three terms so that's not right i
don't see an r plus s anywhere up here
so let's
let's try statement number two
statement number two
u
is equal to
one minus r
and v
is equal to one minus s
so this this this seems like it could be
interesting because there it allows us
to essentially reduce this question
which is a question of four variables
and turn it into a question of two
variables by substituting u and v with
these things so let's do that let's
let's turn the statement into a
statement of two variables
i'll switch colors just to ease the
monotony so the left hand side is
r squared plus s squared is equal to u
squared well now they're telling us that
u squared is one minus r
squared
plus v squared well v is one minus s one
minus s squared
and let's just keep simplifying r
squared plus s squared is equal to
one minus two
r plus r squared plus one minus 2s plus
s squared
see we can
get rid of we can subtract r squared
from both sides
we can subtract s squared from both
sides
and we're left with
is equal to 1 2
minus 2 r
minus
2 s
and let's see
we can
bring the r and the s terms over the
other side so
add 2r plus 2s to both sides so you
bring them over you get 2r
plus 2s is equal to 2.
divide the whole thing by 2 both sides
you get r plus s is equal to 1.
interesting
so when you put apply these two
constraints
on our original question
the question gets reduced to this
if we know that statement two is correct
the question that the problem was asking
gets reduced to this it's saying if we
know that this happens then the question
is true if this is true
well just with statement 2 alone we
don't know that this is true
but as you see statement 1 tells us that
that is true so if you use both
statements together you know that this
question is correct this question is
true
and that was actually pretty interesting
and a little bit hairier than normal
normally you can identify immediately
just by eyeballing it but anyway i'll
see you in the next video